they're bizarre and and radical woke
rhetoric about hurricane Ian continues
because of course they're going to
combine it with climate change and
immigration and a whole bunch more uh
here's noted alcoholic Congresswoman
Nancy Pelosi uh talking about the
hurricane and immigrants and why we need
these people or something
we have a shortage of workers in our
country and you see even in Florida some
of the farmers in the Growers saying why
are you shipping these
immigrants up north we need them to pick
the crops down here okay first off back
in the day or if say yesterday a
republican said that that we need these
people here to pick crops they'd be
called racist when they do it of course
she's not racist also they're not
immigrants Nancy they are illegal
immigrants if you were shipping legal
people from state to state against their
will that would be a problem and I'd be
siding with you uh but these are illegal
immigrants who come to our country
because your elderly gentleman
pretending to be President Joe Biden
refuses to defend the Border also I have
not heard I am fairly well-versed in
Florida politics at this point I have
not heard anyone any crop grower or
orange Orchard Guy saying that we needed
those 50 people that we sent to Martha's
Vineyard so that they could pick their
crops but you see the way they view
these people she doesn't even view these
people as human she is the one who have
used these people as people they should
just be here to pick our crops we need
them to pick our crops